Corey what are some of the tell-tale
signs when you say have a student in one
of your classes that they're using this
old model that it may just be three
years sort of an outdated way but but
what are some typos so when I work with
writers I separate story design from
story execution so story design is just
so if you were going on a vacation and
you wanted to have a romantic relaxing
vacation and you ended up in a war zone
where people are completely getting
killed
there's no room service because
everyone's dead dead bodies in the pool
can you have a relaxing romantic
vacation and the answer is you could but
it's very unlikely if you go to a very
relaxing romantic resort and
everything's perfect that doesn't
guarantee that you'll have a relaxing
romantic vacation because you still have
to have the vacation and you might be
stressed you might be thinking about
work you might be having a fight with
your partner but if you go to a very
relaxing romantic spot you you get there
in a fly first class or you take a night
train through Europe and every the
design of your vacation is just perfect
it makes it so much easier to have a
relaxing romantic vacation the mistake
that so many writers make is they have a
problem with their story design but they
try to fix it through execution so
that's like during a war zone let's turn
the volume up so we don't hear the dead
people as much let's take the dead
people out of the pool yes that does
make it better but just leave and go to
Hawaii and you'll be in much better
shape so I always start with story
design to make sure people I'm sorry if
I could back up so the key is when
someone's having a problem with their
script is it a problem with design or is
a promise execution because other
writers will have a great design but
they'll mess it up in execution get
feedback that it's not working and throw
their design out so if there's a problem
with design and you keep trying to fix
it in execution that's like rearranging
the deck chairs on the Titanic but at
the same time you might have a great
story design that you just aren't able
to find the right execution so people
will often do a consult with someone and
the scripts pretty good but the ending
is terrible and when I talk to them
always comes up we're like well that's
not my original ending and I go what is
your ridge line and when they tell me
I'm like that's a great ending like I
know but everyone said I didn't believe
it it was trite they have one had
criticisms they were criticizing the
execution not the design so he sorry
about taking the long way around to the
question but so when I'm working with
story design it's when someone is
working from a formula or a paradigm or
a set of rules first of all you're just
not interested when you hear it it's
incredibly predictable and it just feels
generic it feels like an Ikea piece of
furniture it's like I've seen this story
a million times and the other key thing
is at some point I'll just stop them and
I'll say why does this happen like why
did the character do this and the real
answer is because the writer wanted or
needed or felt like they needed the
character to do this so it's not
authentic its non-organic and it's not
the best way of telling the story it's
it's literally following a recipe okay
so how are you I'm fascinated by this so
let me just see if I can understand the
difference between design and execution
so design is like the structure of it
and they're doing this perfect sort of
three-act structure but it's too
predictable
whereas execution are the little details
on also execution is actually when
you're writing so it's the dialogue it's
the characters it's the comedy it's the
actual writing of it the design is
having the entire story worked out
before you've written a word okay and
you need to be able to create pitch
perfect design and then execute it
authentically where these are real
characters that were compelled with and
everything that's happening feels this
is really what the character would do
but it also is what's really interesting
to the story because the problem that a
lot of writers get into is if they
slowed things down they'd realize that
there's key points in their scripts
where they ask themselves if this was a
real person this character what would
they really do and let's say it's this
they would do this then they ask
themselves from a story point of view
what makes for the most interesting
story and it's that and so some writers
will just do what the
character would actually do and their
scripts feel very organic but they're
not strong stories other writers will
follow oh this is what makes for the
best story but so they have good strong
structure but doesn't feel organic or
believable so one of the key skill sets
and so when I work with writers this is
the the first thing that I teach them
and I think that this is the
foundational skill set and I call it
creative integration and so the way it
works is writers tend to work from one
of two places inside themselves and it
has to do with the brain and there are a
conceptual part of the brain and
intuitive part of the brain and most
writers tend to be more conceptual or
more intuitive so conceptual writers
tend to work outside in they tend to be
very concerned about the story that the
story's logical that the story makes
sense that the story is interesting to
other people conceptual writers are very
concerned about what other people are
going to think about this writing and
will they think this is good I think I'm
a good writer so they want really
interesting things happening and they
want a lot of interesting things
happening and they want it to make sense
and they wanted to have causality and
that's really really important to them
intuitive writers are completely
different the intuitive part of the
brain doesn't care what other people
think it just cares about what is
authentically true to you so intuitive
writers are navigating towards what they
would do in that situation or just
what's interesting and compelling to
them or what the character would really
do and it's a very different way of
writing one the conceptual is outside in
and the intuitive is inside out so a
conceptual writer would say I have this
great idea and I've got to figure it out
I got to break the story before I could
write it if you don't know where you're
going how you're going to get there it's
a very systematic logical approach to
writing the intuitive writer is going to
be someone who says I need to write this
out to figure out what the story is they
find it through the journey they find it
through
boring intuitive writers explore
conceptual writers decide and they each
have different inherent strengths and
weaknesses so let's start with
conceptual writers conceptual writers
when you ask them why did you write this
what why is this script important to you
it's almost always a big idea a what if
something that could be commercial a new
way of doing a comedy I thought this was
a great idea for a horror film or it's a
theme they want to explore an
intellectual theme and so they're really
good at big ideas big concepts and
they're really good at making sure
everything happens for a reason and
there's forward momentum and there's
causality and they have lots of
interesting things happening that we're
just not that interested in and one of
the reasons we're not that interested in
it is their characters are never
compelling enough their characters feel
kind of like they were invented to tell
this story because they work they're
kind of like puppets who are there to
tell the story and we just don't get an
emotional connection to the characters
the other reason that they hit a glass
ceiling they can't get through is
there's all these interesting things
happening in the script but we're not
that interested in them because we don't
feel anything because the writer didn't
feel anything when they wrote it and
it's an energy transference business so
conceptual writers got great ideas lots
of big great things happening but the
characters just aren't where they need
to be and it's just not emotionally
engaging and most of those writers know
that they don't know what to do about it
and Tudor writers are the opposite
they bleed on the page and these
characters are like real people to them
they don't invent the characters they
don't designing the characters they
discover them and that's why a lot of
intuitive writers don't often get lonely
when they write because they're spending
time with their friends or spending time
with people that they care about and so
if I'm working with a conceptual writer
and the character is not engaging enough
they'll say well what can we do to
change it should we make her older
younger let's make her bisexual let's
change or ethnicities let's take her arm
off let's make her a college drip lijek
what
can we do the maker if I'm working with
a deep intuitive writer and their
characters aren't interesting enough
that would be like talking to a mom and
saying your daughter's not that popular
at school let's take her arms off let's
make her a quadriplegic let's make her
older it'd be like that's crazy this is
a real person you can't change who they
are intuitive writers like they're very
connected to their characters and as a
result they tend to create really
compelling characters really compelling
emotion and these really compelling
characters are forever searching for a
compelling story they can't find because
the intuitive writer is so inside out
and so connected to emotion and
character that part of them cannot
create strong story it's the the
conceptual brain has a perpendicular
processor and it has a certain way of
syncing and strength so weaknesses lean
to the brain as a parallel processor and
anyone if they're interested on you can
email my my assistant which is Lisa at
Quarry Mandel net and we can get you a
bunch of information on this if you're
interested but to take this further what
happens is most writers if not all
writers when they're writing they're
trying to write the best script they can
write and if you're smart and writers
are very smart you play to your
strengths and you hide your weaknesses
so if I was a playing tennis against you
for the championship and I'm really good
at my forehand but I'm weak at my
backhand I would try to play everything
in my forehand and hide my and you of
course would try to make me plate my
back here so writers are always writing
to their strengths and trying to hide
their weaknesses and maybe they know
they're doing it maybe they don't but
they're doing it I see this all the time
and so what happens is over time as
their strengths get stronger and their
weaknesses get weaker and that is why
there's so many writers who poor heart
and soul and all this time and energy to
have a career and they can't get there
because your scripts aren't quite good
enough
you